[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i'm going
to explain a japanese fantasy mystery
film called sakurata reset
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
the premise of the movie is set in a
small town somewhere in japan called
sakurata while at first glance it looks
like nothing special the reality is
quite different half of the residents of
the town have some kind of unique
ability
some can talk to animals some can
teleport while a select few can even see
the future these abilities can only
exist inside of the town because as soon
as the residents step out they forget
about their past lives the protagonist
of the movie is a high school boy named
k asai he has one of the rarest
abilities to remember everything he has
ever seen kay is friends with a girl
from his class named haruki she has the
power to reset time back three days kay
and taruki frequently work together to
use their powers for good and help
people on the morning of september 17th
kay is on his way to school a kind girl
named minami wishes him a good morning
and cycles away seconds later she gets
hit by a van and is on the verge of
death haruki sees this and asks kaye
when the last reset was when he gives
her the green light she uses her
abilities to go two days in the past to
september 15th after using the power no
one other than k can remember what
happened hence he tells haruki
everything about minami's accident
however since they cannot forcefully
change the present kay thinks of a
different plan he goes to meet a guy
named tomoki who has the ability to talk
to anyone telepathically september 17th
arrives again and a few seconds before
minami's accident takes place tamoki
telepathically asks her to stop she does
so and is saved without anyone doing
anything significant then kay and taruki
meet on the roof happy that they were
able to help someone even though minami
doesn't know it they saved the current
time in haruki's phone which means they
cannot reset past this time in the
future which ensures minami is safe to
manage the powers and protect the people
of sakurata an organization called the
administration club is formed it holds
the records of every person in the town
and their abilities and uses them when
necessary for the town's benefit in the
following scene we are introduced to
arie a girl who has the ability to steal
other people's powers but cannot use it
she used to be one of kay's classmates
and used to treat him like a hero long
ago he helped her get rid of her abusive
father however they grew apart with time
and arie still holds a grudge against k
for neglecting her that day she meets an
employee from the administration club
who wants to help her to steal an old
man's power when arie hesitates the
employee asks her if she wants to be
better than kay and manipulates her into
doing it kay and haruki work for a lower
branch of the administration club called
the service club the help they provide
to people is authorized by this club
later that day kaye goes to meet the
manager of the service club he is told
about an old man named cesano whose
power was recently stolen by arie the
club appoints him to meet sasano and
help him somehow in the following scene
k and cesano are together he reveals
that he could enter into any picture for
10 minutes before arie stole his powers
but for his power to work one must tear
the picture right in front of where it
was taken how the hell did he figure
that out after the meeting kay gets a
call from the manager who tells him that
someone very important from the
administration bureau wants to meet him
and taruki urgently kay is confused
because he doesn't remember being
acquainted with anyone from the
administration club still the next day
he and haruki arrive in front of the
club's special quarter they are welcomed
by a mysterious man who refuses to
answer any questions he politely brings
him inside the building that looks like
a maze haruki is asked to stay in the
waiting room until kay meets the
important person since the person can
only see one of them at a time they
oblige and kay makes his way to the
inner quarter the vip turns out to be a
70 year old woman she claims that she
doesn't have a name and requests him
call her the witch she has the rarest
ability to see the future which is why
she has been trapped in the building for
the past 51 years the administration
doesn't want someone with such a
dangerous ability to live in society and
they also cannot let her go away and
lose an asset to the town hence they
have been receiving her help to predict
the future of the town while
simultaneously keeping her captive this
is honestly kind of what working from
home feels like a flashback shows us
little k returning home from school one
day a stranger hands him a phone urging
him to talk to someone the person on the
phone is none other than the witch she
invites him to her town knowing that his
fate is to help its people kay obliged
and never returned home to his parents
since that day before the two can take
the conversation any further the guard
interrupts them kay is asked to leave
while the witch goes to talk to haruki
then we see the old woman asking haruki
how much she loves kay haruki replies
that even if she has no limbs no senses
and no thoughts she would still love him
but if she was missing her arms legs
nose ears mouth and brain would kay
still love her to kay's surprise he
meets arie outside the quarters she says
she wants to steal haruki's power next
kay tries to ask her why but they are
interrupted when haruki returns before
kay can save her he is held back by a
girl named marasi she has the ability to
make things feelings and thoughts
disappear at will and can kill kay with
a single trick holding him hostage the
girls steal haruki's power before
walking away marasi orders kay to make a
detailed map of the witch's lodge in
order for the power to be returned after
the incident kay and haruki return to
the manager's office and meet their old
friend sakagami his power is that he can
transfer one person's ability to another
since k remembers how haruki used her
powers they hope they can transfer the
knowledge from k to haruki they go
through the procedure but when haruki
tries to reset the powers don't work
later k and haruki are returning home
when she asks him if their relationship
is going to change now that she cannot
help him anymore kay says he doesn't
know which hurts haruki since she is in
love with him after dropping her off kay
goes to meet the manager yet again and
asks him how he knows marasi the manager
is shocked but reveals that he used to
be best friends with murasi's elder
brother who died in a traffic accident a
flashback shows us that marasi the
manager and their friend had barged into
the administration's headquarters
threatening to blow up the building if
they didn't help them resurrect
morassi's brother but as expected the
help never came and mourassi became
vengeful currently her mission is to
steal the power from the witch and take
over the administration club with a more
inclusive organization this is why she
wanted a detailed map of the witch's
special lodge somewhere else the old man
cesano tears a picture of his lover from
50 years earlier when the picture comes
to life it is revealed that the woman in
the picture is the witch she was taken
away from him by the administration
bureau which ended their relationship
but neither of them have stopped loving
each other even now cesano tells the
young witch that he misses her but she
doesn't know how the older version of
herself feels about him she looks at his
future and comments that they will need
kaye's help
at home k is doing his best to make the
map as accurate as possible suddenly he
comes to a realization that if marasi is
about to steal the witch's power the
witch must already know it since she can
see the future then he remembers how
morossi and arie were right outside the
lodge when he and haruki visited the
witch this means they are being lured in
or tipped by the witch herself she plans
to use the girls to escape captivity
upon focusing deeper k also sees that
the books arranged on sasana's shelf are
exactly the same as one in the lodge the
next day kay goes to meet him and asks
him if he is hiding something sasano
reveals that he was tipped about k
through one of the pictures of the witch
and that is why he wanted to meet him in
reality his power was never stolen
because he wasn't wearing glasses when
arie tried to steal it sasano doesn't
know how but he has a feeling k will
help him and the witch reunite he gives
kay a picture of the witch and asks him
to meet her kay and taruki go to the
beach the picture was taken at and enter
it the young witch sees kaye's future
and figures out everything that is going
on she confirms that she manipulated
arie and marasi against the
administration so they can help her
escape on september 19th at 9 18 pm they
will come face to face with her older
self the group has to do something right
then to save the witch and help her
escape after returning to the school kay
and haruki meet marasi and give her the
map however they refuse to keep their
end of the deal until tomorrow since it
will be three days after the last reset
which means haruki won't be able to
change the past again kay has decided to
help the witch but not by hurting or
deceiving morassi he gathers sasano
haruki and two of his other friends and
makes an elaborate plan to execute the
next night at exactly 9 18 pm morassie
and arie manipulate the guard and make
him take them inside the lodge using the
map she reaches the witch's room all
this time sasano has been behind them
taking pictures of every open gate for
later use when there is only one door
left to be opened kay stops marasi and
tells her that the administration club
won't be defeated with this method she
extends her hand threatening to kill him
but k doesn't stop he asks haruki to
reset which makes arie laugh knowing
that haruki cannot use her power until
she gives them back suddenly kaye asks
marasi to persuade arie to return the
power and deliberately gets killed using
her hand marasi is shocked because she
never meant to hurt anyone she breaks
down crying and screaming at kay's death
the only way for her to reverse what she
did is by resetting time she asks arie
to return haruki her power when arie
refuses she is also manipulated mentally
in the end haruki gets her ability back
before she resets time cesano gives the
polaroid pictures he took to marasi that
way she will not forget what happened
when the time goes back to september
17th here's some pictures of the present
so that you can remember the future when
you go to the past simple right in the
following scene k and haruki are on the
rooftop and the date is september 17th
again haruki doesn't remember what
happened for the past two days so kaye
explains everything from their meeting
with the witch to her power being stolen
she asks kay if their relationship will
change if she were to actually lose her
powers this time kaye answers that he
would put his life at risk to bring her
power back if something like that
happened in the following montage we see
k reliving everything he did for the
past two days when he goes to meet the
witch he finds marasi outside with the
polaroid pictures she was given she
regrets what she did and promises to let
the two be this time inside kay secretly
puts a bunch of polaroids inside the
witch's pocket without the guards
noticing the pictures are of the open
gates of the facility the next day she
tears them one after another and runs
away through the open gates in the last
scene k is by the road when a car stops
in front of him sasano and the witch are
inside having already reunited with each
other they plan to go outside the city
and leave their powers behind the movie
ends as k and the witch thank each other
this seems like a happy ending but it's
basically the equivalent of the avengers
noping off of planet earth subscribe for
more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching